[Musique]
le collège titan au port a organisé ce
lundi 19 septembre une journée éleveurs
collégiens dans le cadre d'une
convention de partenariat signée entre
le département et la rive association
réunionnaise interprofessionnel de la
volaille et du lapin
l'objectif soutenir les éleveurs
réunionnais et inciter les jeunes à une
alimentation saine et au goût des
produits locaux je ne vois que for me
gêne un peu sinon il y aura tous souvent
vers avaler les fast food est un peu le
truc comme ça et nous bien en tant qu
ils veulent un nouveau gardien le plus
traditionnel mais économiquement les
cieux les poulets mieux vous nous aussi
les élèves il commencé de plus plus
jeunes à connaître consommer les pays et
en même temps me pose est aussi la
qualité le pécule est mieux qu un groupe
d lyon briand depuis deux ans le collège
titan s'inscrit dans une action de
développement durable intitulé éco école
le thème de cette année est l' équilibre
alimentaire
aujourd'hui l'intervention de monsieur
payet
look ever de volaille au tévelave cette
invention donne le départ de notre
projet équilibre alimentaire mais au
départ en fait monsieur payet intervient
dans l'établissement pour la
valorisation des produits locaux c'est
une démarche que
le département mène depuis quelques
années et le collège titan
utilise valorise les produits locaux
dans la cuisine l'éleveur par un
expliqué aux élèves tous les secrets de
son métier les différentes étapes de
l'élevage et les diverses espèces
comestibles
une matinée qui a beaucoup plu aux
collégiens et peut aborder tous les
blancs et donc les chefs et les jeunes
les manches des maïs et la vigne est
jeune et le pool et blanc ne mange pas
de passer par là ça serait
le plus les jaunes se hisseront l'élève
lui qui longtemps on le nourrit plus de
maïs et bien
le pool et blanc l'élève pour longtemps
le poulet coco sens et
c'est bien élevé c'est fait
c'est une campagne qui l'a produit dabo
à l aps les vraies images
après ça va à l'abattoir
pense sincèrement une liste est très
intéressant
plus sûr que non
c'est que les les volailles sont
bienvenues le fait un portrait de
l'éleveur a été opéré dans la comptine
en présence de tous les collégiens qui
ont ce midi-là déguster des produits à
base de volaille pays
[Musique]